[Music]
here we go again it's time for the ps+
essential lineup for the month of
November 2023 the following games will
be available to download from about
midday on Tuesday the 7th we have a mob
classic an asymmetric action game and a
squad shooter let's do this Mafia 2
Definitive Edition kicks off the month a
remastered version of the much loved
20110 outing as we walk the streets of
Empire Bay in the 1940s and 50s this
open world gangster Fest took the
formula of GTA 3 and 4 and applied it to
the American Mobsters the story follows
veto who needs to pay his father's debt
to secure a better life and ends up
being pulled into this underworld and
soon becomes an enforcer missions range
from light-hearted driving to balls to
thewall gunfights with a few plot twists
to add a little drama too the story of
family loyalty and betrayal is
definitely the highlights of Mafia 2 and
there is an element that Mafia 2 does
better than GTA 4 cover shooting which
you you will need for one mission in
particular a thing to note is that this
is a remaster of a 2010 game which is
pretty much just a visual upgrade as
many of the OG issues are still here and
it still feels like a PS3 game at times
random fact Mafia 2 broke the record for
most profanity in a video game with 397
F bombs dropped will you play Mafia 2
Definitive Edition next up is Dragon
Ball the breakers an asymmetric action
game where one person plays as an
overpowered Dragon Ball villain who is
against a team of seven players who must
work together to outsmart that lone
Warrior a temporal seam has occurred
which summons in one of many heavyweight
Dragon Ball characters into this world
we don't have a chance to stand and
fight them and instead must achieve
multiple smaller goals while staying out
of their sight once achieved the group
can escape or send the Raider back to
their own timeline but surprisingly a
weird GAA mechanic is here which
arguably makes some elements here pay to
win at least it was like that when I
played about a year year ago as with
many asymmetric games playing with
friends is so much better than random
lobbies online next a third person
shooter from the aliens Universe aliens
fire Team Elite is a co-op shooter
designed for three players online and is
set 23 years after the OG movies as we
play as a colonial marine on board the
uas Endeavor by the way if you decide to
play alone AI will fill the other spots
in your squad so you're never really
actually alone you'll soon be overrun by
Xenomorphs as countless firefights erupt
which are designed to be intense and
stressful that feeling of uncertainty
does much of the heavy lifting to make
this world feel alive and threatening
especially when the only light you have
is a torch or flashlight in the dark
aliens fire Team Elite has a 10-hour
Campaign which is segmented into four
stories and honestly is really there
just to set up the crazy situations your
squad is forced into with seven classes
to choose from and more than 20 weapon
types there is a lot of variation beyond
that typical 10-hour playthrough and and
platinum Hunters you should be aware
that the extreme and insane difficulties
of this game needed for the final trophy
are incredibly difficult but if you just
want some mindless shooting with friends
aliens fire Team Elite is perfect so
what you playing this month happy mad
delighted sad let me know your thoughts
in the comments below I think I'm going
to jump back into Mafia 2 what about you
I'm Adam you're awesome it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next
[Music]
[Applause]
time
to
[Applause]
my